salut je m'appelle fabien olicard dans
ce format nous abordons un point en
particulier du cerveau dans les
commentaires des épisodes précédents
vous m'avez proposé d'aborder la
concentration ce sera donc le sujet du
jour bienvenue dans la matière grise
[Musique]
dans cet épisode vous allez vivre quatre
expériences expérience une multi tâches
expérience 2 concentra tu seras pinus
expérience 3 c'est à vous expérience 4
dollar ou du lard le tout avec la
présence très appréciée de amics m
[Musique]
la concentration c'est la capacité du
cerveau à se focaliser sur une seule
tâche ce qu'on appelle la concentration
permet de bloquer les informations
extérieures comme les sons environnants
mais aussi nos propres pensées qui au
lieu de s'égarer focalise au même
endroit alors dans cet épisode je veux
que l'on puisse voir si nous pouvons
nous concentrer sur plusieurs tâches en
même temps si nous pouvons vraiment
rentrés en concentration rapidement et
surtout est-ce que la concentration nous
donne vraiment un avantage cérébrale sur
ce que nous faisons est ce que nous
sommes vraiment multitâche aujourd'hui
il n'est pas rare de faire plusieurs
choses en même temps il ya même de
fortes chances pour que vous soyez en
train de faire autre chose tout en
regardant cette vidéo les neurologues
france et co chine et sharon de l'inserm
ont utilisé des techniques d'imagerie
médicale pour analyser l'activité
cérébrale de personnes en mode
multitâches avant de vous parler de
leurs résultats on va mettre notre
invitée sous tension mais pas que vous
aussi car vous allez pouvoir faire le
test en même temps que lui
expérience une c'est la concentration ta
spécialité
waouh je dormis de trois heures s'est tu
m'invites pour la bonne thématique
exactement que je vais te faire passer
des images c'est une prise d'otage de ce
qu'il allait faire dont certaines ont
une thématique connexes qui est la plage
c'est la plage ok ça c'est clair pour la
fille de trois ans et c'est clair donc
je fais passer des images et toi au fur
à mesure dans ta tête tu dois compter le
nombre image qui appelle qui
appartiennent à la thématique de la
plage d'accord en même temps que tu va
compter la thématique les images de la
thématique de la plage tu va compter le
nombre de fois où je dirais le mot
cerveau cette série et on va voir si le
cerveau est capable d'être multi tâches
c'est vraiment le but de ce test la
prostate c'est parti pour la première
image ouais donc tu dois avoir le
cerveau très concentré pour ça tu vois
cérébralement c'est toujours un petit
peu plus compliqué parce que tu dois te
concentrer sur ce que je dis avec les
clubs de ton cerveau et en même temps se
concentrer sur les images et analyser
est ce que ça fait partie du même groupe
parce qu'en fait dans le cerveau on a
des populations de neurones qui nous
permettent de stocker à droite ou à
gauche du cerveau dans les deux cas on
le comprend on d'ailleurs on dit souvent
qu'il ya de plusieurs types de cerveau
genre le reptilien où les choses comme
ça c'est pas vraiment vrai en fait on
sait que le cerveau se construit tout
d'un coup en même temps tu vois tu me
dis si je vais trop lentement je peux
toujours accélérer tu vois ça marche
parce qu'on veut on sait que toi tu as
une vitesse cérébrale très rapide
cérébrale s'est pas cerveau on confond
peut pleuvoir à la plage en a rien donné
au soleil oui peut pleuvoir non mais
quoi de quoi je suis resté bloqué à 5
sur ma main droite mans à oui ça n'a pas
marché ça sera pas
atteint on affine n'en a pas fini
appelez ça peut absolument pas fini mais
là je suis super du fils aimant de la
réalité ok on rassure toi on a terminé
alors combien de fois j'ai dit mon
cerveau s'il te plaît j'ai arrêté de
compter un moment donné donc est ce que
parce que je te dis le vrai chiffre ou
une estimation papa tu dis toi que ta
vie en dépend ok comme ça y'a pas de
prix ça ok mars
7 et cette image je veux dire cette es7
et cette fois cerveau alors pour cerveau
je vais te dire le chiffre précis que je
n'ai pas compté moi même c'était l'impro
crise cette jolie incroyable je pense
que j'en ai raté de schmidt arrêté à 5
ok mais tu t'es dit potentiels - n'a de
plus pas mal les images et bien ça c'est
facile à vérifier
si je dise que ça quand ses plages qui
me dit plage comme ça parce que ya une
chose qu'ils ont interprétés alors claj
banon non merci les châteaux dit non non
non non c'était tout à fait plage
maillot lensois le meilleur choix
de géométrie
des
plagiats déboule sur la page est arrivée
des petites et quant aux quais de lampes
de chevet très peu c'est vrai ça peut
arriver c'est le trompettiste lhc a dû
arriver chichi
[Musique]
bibalou je m'emballe donc non le soleil
absolument on préfère en tout cas toutes
les salles du stress est très peu et
devinette ça ne s'est pas franchement 6
sur 7 + 7 sur 7 sur le cerveau
bravo bref c'est à dire que tu es une
très bonne concentration équipe est très
sympa ce qu'ils applaudissements non
mais c'est essayer c'est pas mal du tout
parce qu en bresse donc c'est très très
dur parce qu'on fait travailler des
circuits différents du cerveau ça veut
dire que quand même on s'en fout des
trois heures de sommeil et tout ça veut
dire que tu as le cerveau exercé à
penser à plusieurs choses en même temps
où on est c'est pas de penser à
plusieurs choses en même temps ça a
basculé d'une tâche à l'autre en
permanence et en vrai en tant que
créateurs de vidéos aux chefs
d'entreprises etc tu dois passer ta vie
en fait à faire alterner les gens de
coeur exactement et c'est ce qui permet
aussi de faire ça en même temps dites
nous un peu dans les commentaires ce que
ça a donné sur vous moi très clairement
en ce moment de ma vie ce genre de
choses peut me gonflait
sectorise pas les trucks et y'a pas pire
pour la charge mentale c'est à dire
c'est pas parce que tu sais le faire que
tu t'y habitues ras de la lecture à
jamais y a pas pire que de passer
augmenter les choses est de passer de
l'un à l'autre en permanence pour la
concentration médias demandent un effort
énorme parce qu'en fait c'est genre je
voyais ça comme de colonnes que tu dois
remplir dont l'habitude du cerveau c'est
le tube où tu comptes les choses de
plage sauf qu'en fait l'exercice de
merde mais ça va dans quelques colonnes
ça déjà juste ça c'est terrifiant au
bout de trois minutes de concentration
cette région est et d'ailleurs ça tout
ça tu le mets dans ta mémoire de
travailler la mémoire de travail en
temps normal elle fonctionne que pour
une seule chose à la fois et elle peut
retenir ou elle peut tenir un compte
mais juste une catégorie à la voiture et
le test le plus complet d'ailleurs ça
aurait été de dire faut que tu compte le
nombre d'image et dans ce nombre d'image
que tu connaisses le nombre d'image de
la même famille plus le nombre de fois
du mot cerveau et je me suis si je fais
ça peut-être s'il s'en va avant la fin
de la vie devient moyen de coupes été
arrêté je sais aussi en plus c'est là
qu'il faut partir bravo absolument merci
merci merci c'est une très difficile je
suis un chargement thème était au
maximum voilà donc je sais pas ce que
c'est les prochaines expériences mais
j'ai peur que déjà je vais vous
expliquer comment ça fonctionne vraiment
ce mode multitâche du cerveau
pourquoi est ce que c'est si compliqué
presque douloureux mentalement de faire
ces deux tâches en même temps la réponse
est donnée par le docteur bayer le
cerveau nous permet de réaliser deux
tâches simultanément si l' exécution est
devenu automatique est inconsciente
grâce à l'apprentissage répétitif c'est
le cas lorsque par exemple nous marchons
et discutons en même temps donc nous
pouvons être réellement multi tâches
seulement si l'une des tâches est devenu
un automatisme ou bien si les fonctions
ne sont pas en compétition entre elles
si les tâches ne font pas appel aux
mêmes régions cérébrales il est possible
de faire un multitâche dire plutôt
convenable le docteur bayer explique que
l'on peut facilement écrire un texto
tout en chantonnant une chanson que l'on
connaît par coeur par exemple par contre
écrire un sms tout en discutant avec le
gain sera quasiment impossible
on pourra pas être concentré sur les
d'heures en même temps comme compter les
images et les mots simultanément au fait
rester bien concentré parce que ce
coup-ci c'est vrai la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui est sponsorisé par
personne donc par mois en parlant de
concentration
pensiez tout connaître de fabien olicard
mais saviez vous que les pandas rôle sur
eux mêmes
peut-être parce qu'ils sont en train de
jouer
peut-être qu'ils essaient de marquer
leur territoire sur blanc sur le sol si
je le fais moi comme si je roule sur le
sol chez moi c'est dur à dire roule sur
l'eau chaude shane roule sur le seul
schéma tant fait pas bien quoi ça me
servirait repart si j'invite un panda
chez moi pour que ça ce que je sache que
je suis chez moi c'est pas facile à dire
la concentration oui mais saviez vous
qu'il est en tournée dans toute la
france avec son nouveau spectacle en
création un spectacle où il crée le
prochain spectacle et il le fait avec
vous dans les petites salles vous pouvez
venir le voir à la fin pour lui donner
votre ressenti en direct live n'hésitez
pas à aller sur le site internet pour
voir quand ça passe à côté de chez vous
voici les dalles qui s'affiche à l'écran
faites vite car c'est rapidement complet
mais ce n'est pas tout ce que fait
fabien olicard car igarka car oui je
vous sens curieux qu'il n'y ait pas les
informations nutritionnelles ci alors
dans le sucre il ya qua na pas de
matière grasse mais il ya beaucoup de
sucre et ouais mais ça ça semble assez
logique ça pas de protéines pas de sel
dans le sucre
le lait oui et ras du cou du coup le
partenariat le parquet oui oui oui on va
se concentrer l1 et oui on respire oui
et concentration oui oui du coup du
pouce et je disais et je vous sens
curieux et curieuses de la curiosité et
cela tombe bien car fabien vous propose
aussi le magazine curieuse
un magazine au format papier que vous
recevez tous les mois dans votre boîte
aux lettres toutes les infos sont sur le
site de curieuses et dans la description
vous voyez à l'écran quelques exemples
de couverture et de sujets qui sont
abordés dans ce magazine maintenant que
vous en savez un peu plus c'est reparti
pour la vidéo quand même curieux cette
histoire de se rouler sur le fun
[Musique]
le trouble de l'attention le plus connu
est probablement le trouble déficitaire
de l'attention avec ou sans
hyperactivité
on l'appelle simplement le tdah
cependant de nombreux facteurs peuvent
entraîner une altération notre
concentration sans qu'il y ait de
troubles associés particulier le tdah ne
peut être diagnostiqué que par un
professionnel de santé donc si vous avez
des doutes la meilleure solution reste
toujours de consulter dans le test qui
va suivre je vais tester les capacités
cognitives de amics m et les vôtres en
même temps
on va faire un test de séquences hockey
et tu vas devoir retenir le maximum une
séquence de couleur tu tues tu vas faire
un certain résultat blessure et après je
vais te faire pour le coup on va
t'asseoir je vais te faire des trois
exercices très rapide de concentration
tata soir
et après ces trois exercices de
concentration ont refait un test et on
verra que tueur à améliorer la
performance d'accord et comme j'ai pas
envie de cette expérience rade dit wak
le deuxième coup il y aura que du verre
comme ça que c'est si rare et si
tu peux regarder du côté du décor
pendant que je mets en place la séquence
il ya une belle grosse séquence énorme
que tu va retenir le plus loin possible
durant quelques secondes tu vas
commencer d'ici et c'est parti déjà
maintenant
évidemment je vais pas te faire chier de
parler en même temps si je sais sinon ça
déconcentre et
acturoutes n combien il ya de plus verte
non je plaisante
là c'est là où le chrono il s'arrête
dans 3 2 1 0 veuillez vous retournez
maxime est ce que tu peux me dire quelle
était la première boule c'est une rose
moudre aux tout à fait deuxième c'est
une bleue t'es sûr oui mais c'est bon
une verte alors précisément oui ouais ok
oui ipad ou sur les couleurs blanc bleu
bleu d'accord
ensuite ces deux jaunes c'est jaune
jaune mais ça marche quand même ouais
jaune jaune excuse moi et ensuite il ya
trois couleurs différentes mort dans
quel ordre fabien tu m'en pose une
question rose bleu vert
rose bleu vert mois fait chier c'est pas
ça ok c'est pas ça ou c'est ça au juste
le valider allez je valide rose bleu
vert alors rose en promet non halal à sa
résistance et bleu du coup ces bleus
bravo maxime tu as retenu de 4,6 cible
ce qui correspond exactement à notre
capacité de stockage dans la mémoire de
travail qui est de 6 à 8 idem que
c'était des boules non mais si oui c'est
ce que du coup tu peux remplacer sa part
d'autres objets du quotidien après les
bulls s'est passé ton victimes sachant
qu'en plus tu avais juste la séquence tu
l'ipad en ordre h m mais tu savais que
c'était ces trois là ouais je vais te
proposait de t'asseoir ici devant ça
marche très très on va faire quelques
exercices de concentration
et le but c'est que tu joues de jeu
mentalement si tu joue pas le jeu
mentalement ce dommage parce que ça ne
fonctionne cela pour l'amusement ok donc
là sans rouvrir les yeux maintenant tu
vas imaginer des rails de train
parallèle devant toi ok tu imagines qui
parles de tes pieds et qui avance droit
devant eux jusqu'à l'horizon ok tu les
regardes absolument à tes pieds tu
continues de les regarder en avançant
lentement jusqu'à l'horizon toi jusqu'à
temps que de voir le l'endroit où ils se
rejoignent en un tout petit point ok là
tu ouvres les yeux tu respires petit peu
prend 2,3 secondes attendu fermer les
paupières
on n'entend que je sens ma voix et tu te
demande aux gens de s'abonner non c'est
pas ça tu veux te referme les paupières
et imagine maintenant un point lumineux
qui serait devant toi tu imagines que ce
sont tes yeux qui contrôlent ce point
lumineux d'accord et que quand tu bouges
ce point lumineux ça écrit en fait sur
une espèce de tableau virtuel devant toi
sur ce que tu veux et donc à chaque fois
tu bouges ses yeux sa bouche ce point
lumineux dans ton esprit es-tu va
simplement dessinée mentalement le
symbole de l'infini en bougeant tes yeux
comme si le prends lumineux était un
marqueur
tu prends bien le temps que tu as besoin
pour visualiser ce 8 allongé tu repasses
sur le symbole au moins trois fois
ok alors tu rouvre les yeux tu respires
un petit peu de nouveaux tu m'avais pas
dit respirer par contre peu d'élus c'est
pour ça je le précise quand même et
tueur ferme les yeux qui va imaginer un
grand tableau devant toi genre un
tableau où on écrivait avec la cré quand
on était petits ce genre de choses est
écrit de t'imaginer que dessus il ya
écrit le mot mental tu dois prendre le
temps de voir le mot écrit de voir les
lettres une par une et maintenant
mentalement tu va effacer le l de mental
avec un chiffon dans ta tête tu les
fasse complètement bien et tu aurais
observe lettre par lettre le moment qu'à
étuve à effacer le a maintenant et tu
regardes les quatre lettres qui reste et
c'est jusqu'à temps de n'avoir plus
aucune lettre je te laisse faire tu le
dis quand tu auras terminé
c'est bon mangez effacer le tableau là
ok on va refaire la même chose que tout
à l'heure durant 30 secondes de nouveau
qui va essayer de mémoriser le plus loin
possible mais avec juste une petite
concentration différente de tout à
l'heure qui vient de ces trois exercices
qui peuvent se faire en une minute dans
sa tête qu'on est habitué c'est parti
hop allez c'est parti je vous écoute
pour la première boule jaune vert vert
jaune vert vert c'est très bien rose oui
jaune oui vers tout à fait
bleus oui ross c'est votre dernier mot
ouais hein c'est une erreur à temps ne
te retourne pas ce que curieux de savoir
ce jeu ouais d'après toi c'était quoi la
fin homme c'était ça pour moi la fin ah
oui d'accord ok en fait tu m'as dit si
c'est la norme je dit je suis fait cette
ligue vote a fait combien du coup tu as
fait un deux trois quatre cinq six sept
ânes plus on va pas se mentir c'est pas
si fou pour la démonstration peut
comprendre leur ferons
mais pas tellement en vrai pas tellement
parce que on se rend pas compte à quel
point un de plus sur juste six éléments
c'est déjà beaucoup tu vois et après il
ya le fait que je te parle en même temps
en fait en réalité j'aurais pas dû
parler des deux si on voulait avoir des
vrais des vraies séquences différentes
mais si l' on te ra seuil et qu'on te
reposer encore un exercice de
concentration on pourra atteindre 8,9
mais pas beaucoup plus ok tu vois dans
ton cas j'ai bien compris ça dépend des
personnes et après je vais beaucoup de
temps sur les mêmes motifs mais motegi
j'ai deux groupes et les couleurs et
d'écrire des scénarios c'est vrai que ça
ressemble à une cheville ah oui à une
chimie après il ya un hippopotame chez
la drogue essentiellement qui chevauche
une banane sur orne océan tu vois et je
me suis dit par groupe de trois ça peut
marcher ça a marché baptisé d'ailleurs
le but et la concertation c'est pas tant
la mémorisation et du coup peu importe
les techniques que tu va utiliser pour
mémoriser en fait c'est juste quelle est
ta capacité à oublier ce qui se passe à
lax à l'extérieur pour être vraiment
focus ligne là dessus et surtout toi
quand tu as l'habitude de faire des
vidéos tu sais qu'il faut donner du
rythme un petit peu de blagues et sera
donc tu es obligé de couper tous ses
automatismes au cerveau pour refaire
focus c'est vrai c'est vrai mais ces
trois techniques qu'on a fait avec
maxime je vous les recommande 6 vous
devez passer un examen à un entretien
d'embauché un truc comme ça juste avant
de rentrer au moins l'exercice de
visualiser le rail comme ça c'est pas
tant de alors visualiser le rail ne sert
à rien de tel j'ai bien senti c'est bien
d'accord par contre ça t'oblige à trop
concentré que sur un truc dans ta vie ok
et d'arrêter de penser à autre chose ce
qui pourrait se passer ce qui s'est
passé at indices us airways 3 0
maintenant on fait un truc à la fois ok
et le petit truc encore avantageux mais
là que forcément tu pouvais pas vivre de
faire ça c'est qu'en faisant ça tu es
obligé de dire arrêter de me parler faut
que je fasse un truc donc en fait été
obligés aussi te couper un peu
socialement pendant une ou deux minutes
le temps de faire ce petit focus la
convenance c'était une excellente
expérience
la concentration peut donc se travaille
et ça c'est une bonne nouvelle nous
pouvons mettre notre cerveau dans un
état favorable à la concentration vous
pouvez aussi simplement visualiser ce
que vous avez à faire juste avant de le
faire c'est un petit peu comme un
entraînement de sportif c'est un
échauffement cérébrale connaître ses
capacités de concentration c'est aussi
bien connaître quand est ce qu'il faut
faire une pause pour continuer d'être
efficace
[Musique]
amics m oui la troisième séquence tu le
sais de matière grise tu m'as dit que tu
étais fan que tu regardais tous les
dimanches avant drucker je regarde les
résumés sur ton instagram est vrai lieu
dimanche après de rigueur ne sait pas
plus du coup ça marche l'expérience 3
c'est le site avoue que c'était hier je
te poses des questions là ça va être
plutôt visuel rigueur par te concentrer
pour ça et ne doivent le faire en même
temps que nous le ce titre assez malin
de c'est à vous de jouer en fait ça
c'est un cheval est absolument sur
lequel je vais poser la première
expérience salle et je me concentre sur
cette grogne sociale la première
expérience c'est le test des ballons
ouais regardez là toujours démontré
simple fabien rey qui en réalité c'est
affreux non non non parce que là c'est
vraiment le test des ballons vous
demander de regarder cette image
attentivement et je ne vous demande pas
quoi regarder précisément vous ne savez
pas sur quoi vous serez interrogé alors
concentré vous parce que moi je les mon
bac 1 c'est à votre tour maintenant
longuet de faire des choix des décisions
d'accord d'après vous quel était le
ballon le plus proche du plafond haha ça
c'est drôle
qu'ils avaient des tailles différentes
fabien qu'une c'est bien ça ben j'aurais
quand même tendance à penser que je vais
te dire de la merde
attends je
veux avoir bon et j'en ai rien à faire
si au montage c'est chiant à des rochers
ce coup d'état là je vais passer une
heure à réfléchir il y avait un gros
ballon au centre est des plus en plus
petit comme ça oui mais ce qu'ils
remontaient c'est la question on parle
du centre du ballon ou du sommet du
ballon du sommet du ballon évidemment le
là elle est si j'avais plus susceptibles
de toucher le plafond
ok ça
c'est un certainement une illusion
d'optique auquel cas c'est alors je veux
dire le plus gros le plus gros parce qu'
il est plus gros geipan pour moi il
était globalement droit donc du sens le
gros mois le rouge d'accord non non
c'est vraiment une illusion d'optique ah
ouais ça c'est pas matériellement
bâtards en fait ils sont vraiment tous
la même hauteur qu'on accorde le
constater ici cette illusion elle
fonctionne très bien le but c'était
pardon mais si c'est gonflé à l'hélium
je te coupe il ira d'abord au plafond
doit presser sur un côté aussi les
laisse penser lequel est le plus proche
du plafond est pas lequel va monter le
plus vite en direction du plafond n'ont
par contre intéressant avec ça c'est pas
de piéger du tout doit vous piéger c'est
de se dire on peut assister à une scène
où il se passe quelque chose et l'a
relaté derrière et se planter sur ce
qu'on dit parce que on n'est pas
vraiment concentrés surtout que la
moindre perturbation une illusion
d'optique ou auditive et c'est peu
trafiqué le souvenir la question à
orienter vers
comme s'il y avait un vague rentes de
bons ils sont où c'est vrai c'est un
truc différentes alors que les suivants
la question que je te pose je vais
orienté ta réponse et c'est pour ça que
les témoignages qu'on fait pas dans les
commissariats les témoins oculaires il
faut énormément de témoins pour être sûr
d'avoir une rare celle de vérité que et
d'être sûr que c'est pas du tout le
ballon rouge il si ça marche ça marche
ok j'ai adoré tests suivants décalé en
pommes en hausse locaux et ont besoin de
ouais j'ai fait une thèse sur sa
trois pommes font trois séries qui ne
nous avait dit donc 10 donc la timone 19
5 mois une noix de coco zapper 2 ça fait
3 donc ça fait causer et 2 j'essaye de
trouver la douille parce que sinon
c'était 5 notre coup c'est 2 5 - 2 ça
fait trois ans associant sauf que là ya
pas de plus donc ouais donc c'est ok
c'est un chiffre auquel on a constaté
des chiffres donc ses
102 +5
c'est pas définitif tu te calmes en fait
je te sens très excité l'arrêt du tout
s'ils savaient que la personne qui
écrivait un commentaire en maintenant
n'importe quoi je vais fait les gros
yeux et mentalist ils sont constamment
en train de
alors écoute 33 pomme ça fait trente
donc ces 10 donc ça fait dix plus une
banane plus
tard et 5 c'est une banane c5 ya pas de
doute donc cinq mois quelque chose ça
fait 3 x et on a neuf au conflit c'est
dire son nom nix étant la note coco
omischl égal 2 on est d'accord donc du
coup 10 x 10 2 c soit prêt je suis a pas
de 6000 à 2 donc faut pas les
additionner donc ces dix deux donc c'est
100 de
plus 507 ouais mais c'est tellement
basique évidemment je me trompe et c'est
la banane qui va toucher le plafond en
première séquence des finances assez
correcte et autres chiffres c'est quoi
ton ombre ses 107 mois jeudi 107 study
107 moi j'aurais dit 25 personnellement
dans une question d'interprétation parce
que moi j'aurais dit que du coup ça si
ça c'est x et ça c'est y qui a multiplié
les deux sens et avec quoi j'ai rarement
vu ça entre des fruits
ça aurait pu se faire look 107 ou 25 on
va dire que les deux réponses
antagonistes et je vois et là aussi
c'est pour juste symboliser en vrai on a
vu tout processus et il est très
intéressant de tous au départ qui dit
allez mange le crack vite fait après qui
dit nathalie baye et marie n'diaye après
le moment où tu as vraiment tour
vérifier en fait il faut trois temps
pour atteindre la vraie concentration
cassel où tu peux être sûr de ta réponse
ou en tout cas puisque tu vas des livres
et en accord avec cette étude ici
peut-être pas ça mais c'est vraiment ça
que je dis maintenant je suis un saric
morel donc il faut à peu près trois
repas ce mental avant de se dire je suis
sûr de m concentré ok c'est tout ce
qu'on voulait démontrer et c'était 25 à
nice selon moi même et participent ce
genre quand il n'y a rien entre une
tomate et une noix de coco c'est un
multiplicateur hockey quand elles sont
l'une sur l'autre cette division si
c'est une pomme c'est une pomme c'est un
trinôme en tout cas c'était des tomates
c'est ouais et un cd pomme
a fait dernier c'est à vous ouais tu
leur as brillamment ma question de ce
panneau sera pourquoi hockey un peu la
question qui se pose de plus en cas de
victoire ok mxm
pourquoi
pourquoi de plus de dégâts le poisson
donc à trois plus trois gars 8 et
pourquoi cette puce est égale triangle
j'ai envie de te laisser seuls avec
compris mais un [ __ ] bravo rapide je
te laisse la primeur de l'explication du
cocma comment superpose des chiffres ça
donne un 2 2 et 2 ça fait un petit
poisson le 3 et le 3g quand on les
retourne à vous retourner en miroir
inversé ouais c'est laiterie verticale
absolument c'est ça oui c'est ça et puis
donc sa fin huit et puis un triangle
dans l'est avec les deux sets bravo
félicitations bravo latieule regarde
même le real il est bluffé l'agent sont
par terre on voit pas et son argent ils
sont y conte ville s'il ya quelqu'un qui
bavent même bravo maxime merci merci
merci pour ce c'est tabou avec un énorme
plaisir
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
malgré ce que l'on pense notre capacité
réelle de pleine concentration est en
moyenne de 8 secondes ça fait mal quand
on se dit que celle du poisson rouge
peut être de 9 secondes innova mais il
ya vingt ans notre capacité de pleine
concentration était de 12 secondes les
chercheurs pensent que cette diminution
est due aux usages numériques notamment
les réseaux sociaux les notifications
qui nous perturbe au final ce n'est pas
un hasard si tik tok cartonne avec ses
format ultra courts ou que des youtuber
fasse un cut ou un zoom toutes les 3
secondes côté des hommes et ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui le rythme est
souvent une manière de ne pas perdre
l'attention de plus en plus courtes de
l'audience autant vous dire que c'est
vraiment l'un vers ce que je fais avec
ce format
j'ai pas du tout comprendre
[Musique]
la concentration ne permet pas toujours
d'empêcher notre cerveau de se faire
avoir parce que son fonctionnement est
habitué au monde qui nous entoure aux
règles basiques et quand certains jouent
avec nos perceptions cela peut créer de
la magie dans nos têtes à condition
d'être
concentré ou l'avenir
mm je te présente anthony bonjour mais
salut mais j'avais juste avant oui c'est
vrai et les oeuvres sont de gerba cner
d'accord ok et on l'appelle bat nerfs
c'est son nom d'artiste puisque pratique
mais c'est là bas c'était une famille il
presque anthony c'est monsieur bactéries
milieu nautique d'en faire mal compris
ils se ressemblent pas du tout en cause
mais vraiment pas antony tu est comme on
dit que le galeriste galeriste qui les
galeristes et il expose entre autres les
oeuvres de bach terre gérard beck nerfs
j'avais fait une vidéo avec lui sur les
oeuvres qui fait qu'ils sont vraiment
atypique il pouvait pas être là
aujourd'hui mais son galeriste est venu
avec des oeuvres sélectionnées vraiment
pour l'occasion qui vont nous permettre
de jouer avec nos perceptions et pour ça
évidemment il faut faire preuve de
concentration et raccords parce que
vraiment j'ai pris mes 10 du règlement
mais j'ai compris je te laisse me
présenter la première oeuvre ben écoute
à cesser une voix qu'il a réalisé pour
rendre hommage pour faire un clin d'oeil
à un artiste issu du street art l'art
urbain qui s'appelle space invaders qui
a réutilisé si tu veux les figurines
deux issus du jeu space invaders pour le
mettre un peu partout si tu veux dans le
monde entier tu en as déjà vu dans la
rue des petits space invaders et donc
forcément ces actions sont interdites et
en fait l'idée c'est justement jouer sur
cette interdiction en faisant flotter
ses oeuvres donc on a on a plusieurs
effets du coup il ya ce côté mélange du
très précis et du flou fait qu'il ya cet
effet de flottaison mais par rapport à
ses petits carrés tu vas voir dans les
intersections apparaître des carré gris
dans toutes les intersections qui
disparaissent dès que tu te concentres
tu les as lundi à cette distance des
peuples et
du couffo pas de concentrer pour voir
les quarts est mana c'est d'actifs x
voilà il ya ce côté aussi apparitions
disparitions qui est intéressant c'est
une oeuvre illusio nantes où t'as pas
besoin d'une explication en fait parce
que juste si tu te noies va le voir
flotter tu vas voir les trucs à paraître
et c'est donc le tout fonctionne est le
même dans les faits et en plus de ça sur
la vidéo elle est très intéressante
parce que celle ci c'est le chemin
inverse il faut pas te concentrer pour
que les illusions un tiens vaut rester
dedans tu dois être très dans le vague
et tu vois apparaître tous les trucs qu
un interstice toutes ces choses qui
n'existent pas moi ça fait partie des
deux choses qui me louis dionne beaucoup
dans les oeuvres de bach ners et les
effets de flottaison avec le flou car
que la chute coller à ça et pourtant
j'ai l'impression de voir fou
deuxième oeuvre anthony alors celle-ci
pour l'instant de près moi je vois rien
de spécial c'est un club pas sauf si tu
munci que vraiment il y avait un petit
saint en plein milieu je ne le vois pas
mais mais là ça me fait rien de ce
dernier un peu de vrai parce qu'il ya
justement un effet de d'apparition et
d'interprétation qui qui permettent de
justement créer quelque chose qui
n'existe pas ok
effectivement le poussin bouge
on découvre qu'en fait ça y est j'y vois
même de côté maintenant ah ouais et des
lignes dans tout cela exactement c'est
incroyable alors que l'attend mais moi
j'ai vu des pointes importe quoi fabien
temps mais moi je vois plein de points à
blaye et j'ai les lignes noires d'accord
c'est qu'il faut voir les panneaux mais
c'est ça justement à ces perspectives
qui équipent de pouce à recréer le vide
enfin enfin le cerveau même pas le vide
donc ils recréent céline et le ski est
encore plus fort si l'accès que le
cerveau les yeux dans créer une densité
de noir plus noir que le noir quand il
est vrai que je mange un peu les yeux
j'ai l'impression qu'ici c'est beaucoup
plus noir que là hélas pas une raison
c'est incroyable c'est juste fou
alors anthony là tu nous mets deux
nouvelles oeuvres de bach nerfs qui
fonctionnent en binôme il a comment
réaliser cette oeuvre pour pour montrer
si tu veux un effet visuel qu'on appelle
l'effet peau geldof est en fait l'idée
c'est les peintres savent détourner la
réalité ont détourné les perspectives
pour que visuellement on voit droit oui
que ce soit équilibré donc si tu veux là
tu crois avoir une ligne oui mais en
fait c'est exactement ce qui se passe là
d'accord ça c'est les deux mêmes
tableaux n'existera le rectangle
exactement tu peux essayer tu peux tu
peux faire tout ce n'est pas facile à
l'heure avec ce que c'était très étrange
a une ligne en commun c'est celle ci
pensait mais en fait tu as vraiment moi
mais c'est fou parce que tu es ouais
c'est ça tu as besoin de vérifier
ce qui me rend ouf c'est que tu te dis
pas tiens il a triché et ça arrive
presque au truc c'est que ça n'a
vraiment rien à voir si la bac nerfs
vous l'avez fait vraiment droite on
l'aurait vu des cas les têtes on
l'aurait vu des cas les way ça c'est du
coup c'est un utilité de faire ça en
fait exactement enfin c'est choquant que
comme vision d'optique mais en plus de
ça c'est mieux quand on triche ne
retenir cette phrase accord contexte
pour la quoi
tu as compris la question maintenant
les gradins gelé enfin je les en vrai
les deux sont stricto strictement
identique c'est exactement à la bella tu
peux faire ce que tu veux tu que tu vois
pas tu ne pourras pas non en cause et
oui parce que je connais ce genre de
mécanisme mais en fait avec la balance
des blancs et paraderont change
d'interprétation ça est plus clair que
ça alors que pas du tout c'est
exactement la même couleur où ils le
font c'est ça marche tu pourrais arriver
à y croire que c'est les deux même foncé
à droite mais leclerc c'est incroyable
c'est parce que c'est vachement lumine
pour elle c'est vachement plus lumineux
à droite qu'à gauche mois
les deux fronts c'est j'arrive à poser
n'importe quoi je n'arrive pas du tout
mais ça c'est plus clair que ça pour
cent pour cent des emplois et seul le
digital peut trouver que c'est
exactement moi j'ai une nouvelle norme
ias pas que le digital j'ai un cutter
sur moi je peux te dire que je vais
couper tout ça c'est de l'art classique
tu sais à quoi on peut voir aussi que ça
marche très bien à tous les
chuchotements de derrière de toute
l'équipe qui saura trader
compris non mais tant mieux parce que ça
montre que ça marche surtout tu vois
merci beaucoup anthony merci et alors un
grand bravo à bach nerfs encore une fois
merci à toi bac nerfs de nous avoir
prêté des oeuvres également et on met un
lien vers tout on travaille dans la
description merci beaucoup
comme vous l'avez vu le meilleur moyen
d'apprécier les oeuvres de bach nerfs
est d'être concentré pourtant très
étrangement on pourrait se dire que
cette attention focalisée pourrait aider
au contraire le cerveau à ne pas se
faire piéger pourquoi tout cela
fonctionne même quand on sait vous le
verrez dans un prochain épisode de
matière grise merci à tous les
participants à toute l'équipe à charles
x man et hulk d'haïti de la production à
loïc à la réal avec toute son équipe est
bien sûr à un mix m n'hésitez pas à
découvrir ces vidéos le lien est dans la
description le prochain épisode de
matière grise sera publiée le mois
prochain comme d'habitude et on parlera
des liens entre le cerveau et le corps
vous pouvez vous abonner gratuitement à
cette chaîne youtube si le format vous
plaît n'hésitez pas à le faire et vous
retrouverez des 13 épisodes très dans de
matière grise dans la description alors
pouvons nous débloquer de nouvelles
compétences à la simple force de la
concentration sommes nous vraiment ancré
dans le présent cette petite loupiote
va-t-elle se rallumer vous aurez la
réponse à tout cela et bien plus dans
les prochains épisodes de matière grise
à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]